なぁなさんどんなんだったんやさぁさぁ
はぁ
ちんちんもなんだこれは絶対えっこれはこれは誰だ
をはどうぞ入ってきたなんか浦々の方の
細いところからうるさい区3位うっう
ブランドバックさあしていいじゃんもう何が目的で俺の家に来た
シャンプーが
シャンプー
違うます違うなーっていう
わーさあ早く出てきやここレジャーやだ何で年間その
シャンプがー
なくてん毛先が傷んでるん
痛んでてた後毛先ないと思うんだーうすべすべっすべつですめしべはい何度は常にんだ
この地球のシャンプが欲しくていますね
# d っっ何か良いのメリットいい
いけないをヴィダルサスーンですよメリットなんですかね
確かなよマジかミスターな hr s ヘッドスパっとのいやいやヴィダルサスーン
乱してるとビタリ山すんじゃねサー人に全部させずなきゃば寄与分
築きたいの虚人に合わないのすごい
沢山ですください2薄味因数アジエンスを浴びだり差す時間使ったことなんかじゃあ
ちょっとコンビニでヴィダルサスーン買ってから帰ってはい
がまだやら帰らない何で何が欲しいの帰りたくないシャープなんでしたペリット
ねそれメリットだったらどうなるのかなんていう自分をとっくに試してみたいよな
わかったわかった君は何か悩みとかあるわけでちょっと暇だから姉御相談に乗って
あげるよ
悩みは最近靴下のことが
やトレ受けるんですよね下界風邪か語って山や向けますか
つっ靴下のかかとや受ければいいですよ僕も破けなかったつ今までずっと
したい金の事ばっかを受けて
なんでだろうがんって言う
これ本当なんですよねっ
なるほどで野犬ちょっと人間だしもう正さんなのですねやっぱり靴下履けますよ
パソ趣味はベイブレードおーこっちの世界だってやっぱ最近流行ってて
やっぱりなんかベイブレードっていうのはコマだけじゃないんですよね
このあとあの
さっ部分でがその紐付ける部分両方がやっぱりあってない子なんですよその
頭のとことかけつの床が英字+
ます
tes
持っています